je vous demande d'accueillir laurent
haug ap
bonsoir bonsoir à tous merci de
m'accueillir
moi je suis un vieux des nouvelles
technologies ça fait 25 ans que je suis
dans ce monde là et en ça m'étonne
toujours de voir le regard qu'on porte
sur sur moi et sur mon métier
j'étais à la radio la semaine dernière
et puis on dit ah vous faites partie de
l'élite
les geeks et l'élite alors qu'il ya dix
ans on était justement les ados
boutonneux à qui personne voulait parler
il ya 15 ans moi quand j'essaie de
parler aux gens leur dire mais regardez
internet c'est intéressant on disait
mais c'est un gadget ce truc est
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que la
technologie c'est ce qui est en train
d'envahir le monde qui va nous mettre au
chômage et c'est passé de gadgets un
truc de masse qui nous a envahi il ya
quinze ans on faisait face au rejet de
la technologie aujourd'hui on est tous à
crosse et le problème quoi on est tous
sur nos smartphones est en fait ce qui
m'étonne toujours c'est que on est quand
on regarde la technologie forcément dans
une extrême soit faut en avoir peur il
faut la rejeter
soit c'est un truc complètement
fascinant limite religieux
j'aimerais en fait c'est de vous montrer
que la technologie il est temps de
remettre à sa place ni en avoir peur ni
en faire une religion
regardons les peur la peur numéro un ce
moment si vous lisez les journaux c'est
y aura bientôt plus de travail à cause
de l'intelligence artificielle
moi mon téléphone c'est toujours pas
reconnaître mon nom mais paraît-il
chômage dans deux ans parce qu'il va
faire mon boulot à ma place et en fait
quand vous regardez l'histoire on a cent
quarante ans de donner un peu sur le
marché du travail est en fait la
technologie crée toujours des emplois
mais qu'est ce qui se passe c'est qu'on
voit qu'il ya des métiers qui
disparaissent et on voit pas qu'au même
moment et des métiers qui apparaissent
aujourd'hui on est en 2018
c'est une évidence pour vous que quand
vous allez au bowling si vous lancez la
balle c'est une machine qui vient
remettre l'équipe ben il ya 60 ans
étaient des enfants qui remettait les
pieds c'est un métier qui a disparu
avant que le radio réveil soit inventé
il y avait des gens qui se baladait dans
les villes avec des grandes tiges comme
ça ils allaient taper au carreau c'était
pour vous réveiller pour aller à l'usiné
ces gens là aujourd'hui non plus travail
fallait allumer les lampadaires les
médecin consommait beaucoup de sangsues
il y avait des chasseurs de sangsues
parce que vous aviez vous avez mal de
tête ou mettre des sangsues un peu
partout ça ira mieux vaut faire une
petite saignée il ya les gens qui
poussait les lettres les compositeurs
vous savez l'imprimante de gutenberg
ces gens là n'existent plus aujourd'hui
parce que qu'on imprime avec photoshop
world et c'est donc en fait on voit des
métiers disparaître mais ça fait depuis
toujours que les métiers disparition
vois pas qui est des métiers qui
apparaissent aujourd'hui vous pouvez
être pilotes de drones vous pouvez être
professionnel de esport vous pouvez
écouter de la musique pendant votre
textos qui n'était pas prévu vous pouvez
être éleveur d'algorithmes master si
votre rumba se comporte mal vous pouvez
l'amener à quelqu'un qui va lui
apprendre à bien se comporter vous avez
tout un tas de coach vous être
modérateur de contenus sur facebook ou
sur youtube c'est des jobs qui
n'existaient pas et quelques années et
donc une de ses peurs c'est qu'on ne
comprend pas que la technologie détruit
des métiers mais elle ne détruit pas des
emplois ensuite on pense que par rapport
à la technologie on n'a pas notre mot à
dire et ça c'est faux la technologie ce
n'est pas quelque chose qu'on subit est
un exemple historique très connu
la technologie pour automatiser les
ascenseurs étaient prêtes dans les
années 1900 le dernier opérateur
d'ascenseur se retrouvent au chômage en
cinquante ans après le moment où la
technologie est prête elle a été
déployée partout
pourquoi les gens avaient peur de monter
dans un ascenseur ci avait par un
opérateur comme quoi la résistance
sociale à la technologie a un impact
aujourd'hui il ya quelques semaines on a
annoncé la première des consommations en
france les gens en ont peut-être marre
de tout ce qu'il ya dans la bouffe de
tous les suppléments alimentaires etc
donc les gens consomment moins on peut
peser est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on le
voit bien avec les régulations
européennes les jets dpr etc on peut
même peser sur les géants américains du
numérique en fait on n'a plus notre mot
à dire que jamais et aussi la peur des
innovateurs ça me fascine là quand
johnny hallyday est mort on dit johnny
hallyday là
légende il ya 50 ans johnny hallyday va
votre fille vous le ramener à la maison
vous les mettez un coup de pied au cul
tu rentres tu viens pas ici toi les
rockeurs là vous êtes vraiment les
racailles en fait
cinquante ans plus tard ça devient les
légendes et c'est toujours comme ça avec
les innovateurs aujourd'hui nous on a
par exemple des artistes qui sont très
connus compense sont des gens très très
bien et qui aussi dans leur temps
étaient des sacrés et sacré punk c'est
les compositeurs de musique classique
peut-être vous le savez pas mais bac et
a fait de la prison vingt enfants
illégaux c'est un fan de duels qui
étaient aussi illégales debussy
blacklisté parce qu'ils avaient des
liaison adultère fait scandale
retentissant
chopin toxicomanes à l'opium beethoven
alcoolique incurable etc etc c'est qu'en
fait les innovateurs avec le temps sont
acceptés deviennent les légendes est
aujourd'hui bel et rocker c'est les
rappeurs vous avez qu'ils sont censurés
mais c'est un problème qui est vraiment
les récurrents la peur de la technologie
c'est très intéressant ça commence il ya
très très très longtemps
platon quatre siècles avant jésus-christ
dit maintenant qu'on a inventé
l'écriture
les gens n'auront plus de mémoire 16 113
barnaby reach l'abondance des livres est
un problème tout le monde peut faire un
livre c'est pas normal
et à trop de livres il en a écrit 25 lui
d'ailleurs c'est surtout les premiers
livres des autres qui sont un problème
pas ses livres à l'uni xviie siècle il
ya un problème à cambridge
les étudiants gâchent leur vie à faire
quoi à boire du café à lire les journaux
l'université s'insurge contre ces
étudiants qui lisent les journaux quelle
horreur 1815 il ya un maître qui se
plaint que les étudiants ne savent plus
écrire au tableau avec la craie ils
passent trop de temps à écrire sur du
papier et il s'agit de trouver des
choses que les jeunes font mal l'unité
imagination sans limites
1880 le telegraph ça colle porte que des
fake news ça rend les gens nerveux il ya
un médecin américain qui fait un bouquin
qui s'appelle américaine nar witness le
telegraph est en train de rendre la
société nerveuse des gens des crises de
nerfs à cause du telegraph
1900 grand problème social en angleterre
qui dit-on causes des suicides chez les
ados les béninois et foule
qu'est ce que c'est ce qu'en fait on a
popularisé des petites nouvelles qui
sont vraiment pas cher qui raconte des
histoires de d'ados qui font le tour du
monde et ses pions dit voilà ça perverti
la jeunesse 1990 et jeux vidéo rappelez
vous tout cela vous qui avez joué un jeu
vidéo vous êtes tous des criminels en
puissance
bon c'est peur elles sont toujours là
elles sont quelque part normal elles
sont récurrentes et elles sont futiles
en tout cas quand on les regarde avec la
perspective historique
aujourd'hui vous n'avez plus peur quand
vous allumez la lumière chez vous il ya
des gens qui pensaient que l'électricité
c'était une technologie qui était
technologie du diable donc la peur n'a
pas trop besoin c'est pas très pertinent
ça nous aide pas beaucoup
revenons maintenant sur la fascination
la fascination des technologies alors
les voitures volantes promesses du vin
19e jour paris v n'a twitter ne pas les
voitures volantes frigo intelligent
génial vous sortez un truc du frigo le
frigo recommande tout seul de marans 30
ans que ça n'arrive pas
la ville intelligente plus de bouchons
dont
toujours pas toujours pas ça la voiture
autonome y aura plus d'accidents
regardez les news récemment internet la
paix dans le monde
plus de guerre lui toutes les cultures
vont enfin pouvoir se parler
j'ai pas trop si on en est là
la téléconférence sera plus besoin de
voyager plus d'impact sur le climat
regarder les courbes de l'industrie du
transport aérien et caméras de
surveillance on va sécuriser nos villes
et c'est bon la voiture volante
c'est une bonne idée jusqu'à ce que vous
pensiez que votre voisin qui va un petit
peu fort sur la bouteille il va aussi en
avoir une
c'est un peu embêtant les caméras de
surveillance va ça fait le business des
vendeurs de casques de moto ain à peu
près tout ce qui se passe maintenant
malheureusement dans l'espace public il
suffit d'un casque de moto et puis plus
de problème de deux caméras de
surveillance la voiture autonome ça pose
tout un tas de problèmes
il ya un artiste qui a fait un projet
extraordinaire il arrive au tueur une
voiture autonome il prend un sac de sel
et tracent une ligne blanche autour de
la voiture et la voiture elle est un
algorithme qui les lignes blanches ne
pas sortir et du coup elle est bloquée
la blog shane par exemple que le grand
buzz du moment que c'est vachement bien
là blog shane c'est super ça permet de
sécuriser l'information mais bon si vous
rentrez une donnée qui est fausse dans
une block chain vous allez stockées de
façon sécurisée une fausse donné le
facteur humain c'est toujours c'est ce
que vous diront les ingénieurs c'est le
facteur humain est vide news qui est
sorti fin 2016 je crois c'était il ya eu
un problème dans une prison c'est qu'ils
ont mis un bracelet électronique un
détenu sauf que le surveillant l'a
attaché sur sa prothèse de jambe donc le
facteur humain 1 le célèbre facteur
humain mais la technologie en fait est à
double tranchant penser que c'est une
solution magique à tous c'est
complètement faux ça n'arrive jamais
aujourd'hui on en est au point où même
on imagine que l'innovation c'est la
technologie et que sa liasse espèce de
combinaison de fusion entre innovation
et technologie on oublie qu'on peut
innover de plein d'autres façons
différentes
regardez les compagnies aériennes low
cost ce que chez nous venus avec easyjet
qui était fait aux états unis depuis
très longtemps la grande innovation
c'est surtout une innovation de modèles
d'affaires
c'est pas vraiment une innovation
technologique parfois innover c'est
enlever la technologie il faut
réhumaniser aujourd'hui ce que fait la
poste en france c'est fascinant vous
pouvez maintenant demander que le
facteur à y voir votre grand-mère votre
grand père qui est un peu isolé et donc
l'innovation de la poste c'est quoi ces
de réhumaniser le lien avec la
population a beaucoup de technologies de
là dedans en fait c'est intéressant on
voit que dans plein d'endroits la
technologie nous rends mène vers le
passé les musiciens aujourd'hui gagnent
leur vie en allant jouer devant le
public
c'était un peu leur business model ya
une centaine d'années un avant qu'on
invente la musique enregistrée la
gastronomie on revient au local on
revient à l authentique c'est peut-être
qu'on aurait toujours dû faire
l'alimentation on enlève les produits
qu'on n'aurait jamais dû mettre dedans
la santé on est aussi en train de
revenir à des choses peut-être plus on
est pris plus globalement avec un peu
moins de produits chimiques etc
voilà donc innover ça n'est pas que la
technologie et donc il faut arrêter avec
cette fascination de penser que c'est
chaque fois vous allez lire un article
sur une technologie qui va sortir dans
quelques années c'est toujours
miraculeux ça résout tous les problèmes
mais en fait ça n'arrive jamais et comme
il faut pas avoir peur il faut pas non
plus être béat devant ces technologies
chaque fois c'est des opportunités et
malheureusement des défis alors il ya un
troisième truc très inhibant comme ça
c'est cette idée que l'on vit une
période exceptionnelle jamais eu autant
d'innovations ça jamais été aussi vite
alors ça fait peur à plein de gens on
aime bien pensé qu' on est dans une
période exceptionnelle parce que ça fait
de nous des gens exceptionnels notamment
les gens de la technologie assez génial
il en a inventé des trucs super vraiment
make the world betterplace etc
ça fait du bien à l'ego mais c'est pas
vrai ça n'est pas vrai la rapidité du
changement
cet été j'ai passé un moment dans une
station de montagne qui en fait pendant
des années a gagné sa vie en recevant
les tuberculeux savez les sanatoriums et
donc il y avait trois mille cinq cents
patients 80 sanatorium en 1946 cinq ans
plus tard il n'avait plus disruption
savez pourquoi
les antibiotiques on invente les
antibiotiques hyper tous leur boulot
cinq ans maintenant dit ah ça va super
vite ça fait 25 ans qu'on est dans la
révolution digitale
on fête les 30 ans du web l'année
prochaine et je peux toujours pas faire
ce que je veux avec mon téléphone quand
j'arrive sûrement e-banking c'est pas
vrai que ça va vite
et alors l'histoire la période la plus
innovante ça s'est vu ça fait du bien à
l'ego c'est génial de penser ça mais
pareil c'est complètement faux la belle
époque le moment où le centre de
l'innovation mondiale est en france à
paris
c'est trente nouvelles technologies à ce
moment là la vaccination le froid
artificielle l'automobile l'aviation
l'électricité
le telegraph le gaz les supermarchés les
cosmétiques c'est autre chose que les
réseaux sociaux et les moteurs de
recherche
on pense qu'on a
inventer et en fait quand on regarde
bien on arrive en bout de chaîne le
financement participatif super exemple
savez c'est l'invention de kickstarter
dans l'esprit de plein de gens ou en
france qu'est-ce qui ce bang bang et ses
jets aux jambes mais vous êtes aller à
la messe à la fin un petit panier là
c'est du financement participatif
quand on lui parlait des emprunts russes
c'est aussi un cas célèbre c'est pas
très bien fini le financement
participatif ça fait des millénaires que
ça existe en tout cas autant que la
monnaie existe aujourd'hui une des modes
dans l'industrie du commerce de détail
ce qu'on appelle le nouveau retail le
nouveau commerce de détail alors c'est
cette espèce de synergie entre le monde
du online et les magasins réels mais
vous avez entendu parler de la redoute
ou de manufrance ou de sears ou du
printemps fait ces gens là exactement le
même modèle il ya 120 ou 130 ans sauf
qu'il vous envoyer un catalogue c'était
pas un site internet mais c'était la
même chose
il avait un catalogue s'étaient livrés
par la poste y avait des magasins pour y
ramener les objets qui vous plaisait pas
tout ce que fait l'homme masque
aujourd'hui planté comme ça des bornes
de rechargement
mais andré citroën a dû le faire il ya
en 1905 et pas stations-service quand
ils ont inventé les voitures à essence
donc il a fallu pareil allez poser des
voitures à essence inventer un nouveau
business model tout comme vous pouvez
vous pré payé votre modèle 3 bien vous
pouvez vous pré payé votre citroën on
vous l'achetiez comme ça ça leur
permettait de construire l'outil de
production exactement les mêmes idées il
ya cent ans la guerre des taxis qu'on a
connu il ya eu il ya aussi la même gare
des taxis au xviie siècle
quant à londres on a construit des ponts
parce qu'avant les bateliers avait avait
à un monopole d'un seul coup on fait un
pont ils ont dit mais c'est dégueulasse
ils nous piquent tout notre boulot en
plus c'était tous les goûts tous les
gars de la banlieue bien sûr qu'ils
venaient de mes regrets mais arrêtez le
roi a même mis en place des règles
interdisant aux chauffeurs de calèche de
faire des courses de moins de 3
kilomètres comme ça ils pouvaient pas
bosser comme on a voulu faire avec
hubert
en disant vous devez attendre quinze
minutes avant de prendre vos clients la
surveillance d'état aînés c'est le
cabinet noir qu'est ce que c'était c'est
quand sous louis xiv on a inventé le
courrier et puis il y avait un cabinet
noir dans lequel n'a le droit d'ouvrir
les lettres ont aidé cache t on les
remet été bon sur ayant été c'est le cas
du monde la création de devises dans les
cryptes aux monnaies dessous dont on
parle maintenant n'importe qui peut
faire sa monnaie au xviie siècle il ya
400 devises en europe qu'on a déjà été
là les médias sociaux
ça existe aussi depuis très longtemps
sauf que ça se passait un peu
différemment donc quand vous promeniez
comme ça sur une route les review sur
une auberge n'était pas sur internet
elle est écrit directement sur le mur de
l'auberge de jeunesse de les étoiles en
russie c'est nul passez votre chemin
il y avait des tags politique à pompéi
il y avait les césars faisait publier
dans toutes les villes sur un mur les
news venant de rome le mur facebook
dans l'angleterre victorienne les gens
se passait des livres et en fait il
écrivait des commentaires et l'envoyer
aux suivants fièvre des conversations
comme ça qui se déroulait autour des
livres c'est exactement les mêmes idées
et en fait je dis pas ça pour taper sur
mon industrie oumma communauté où le
monde de la tech mais je dis cela parce
que je trouve que c'est finalement c'est
très rassurant le changement il est
permanent
on y survit très bien depuis très
longtemps et à mon avis la technologie
fournie en avoir peur ni en faire une
religion faut simplement la remettre à
sa place
la technologie c'est un outil comme les
autres merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]